can you explain the eight sequence
template sure this originates in two
ways two places it originates in
Hollywood history by the accident of the
one real film 35 millimeter film that
became standardized by the first decade
of the 20th century the first movies by
that by that time let's say that by 1910
there are single real experiences there
are ten minutes long and for various
reasons in the teens of Hollywood split
in two directions from the single real
film to what we call full-length
features multi real films hour and after
two hours three hours and in the other
direction to the serial which is a real
or two installments series and the
reason you have the the origin of
sequences is that in the u.s. the
distribution system was so rigorously
one real a week or two reels a week that
when they started to generate
full-length feature films they were
still distributed a couple of reels a
week so if you look at manuals of the
time it's been writing manuals they're
about 60 titles that came out in the
19-teens on how to write a photo play
because the market was kind of wide open
and people wanted to write these things
you'll get instructions about making
sure that each reel has a climax to it
so that the audience will be interested
in seeing the next reel and then they'll
see the next one after that so it was
almost like a limited series the feature
film by the late teens we are seeing
them all the distribution system is
changing and you're seeing in theaters
what we would normally experience as a
feat full-length feature but the the
idea of writing by the reels survived
into the 20s and 30s and you can see the
scene evidence of it in the
the way the continuity scripts are
marked they're often marked by sequence
letter sequence ABCD and that is where
what we call sequences come the
nomenclature comes from what Frank
Danielle discovered in teaching in the
80s he discussed the three-act structure
in terms of setting up a situation
developing it and then hang it off but
he found that the students struggled
with the middle part of the script
because it's intimidating how do you
fill up 60 pages in the middle and
usually 30 pages to set it up 60 pages
in the middle and 30 pages in the third
act so he revived this idea of sequences
he said well don't think of it in terms
of one you know act of 60 pages think of
it as four 15-minute scripts that each
one builds on the last and so thus the
the sequence approach is born you're not
going to try to tackle a whole 120 pages
just figure out these 15 minutes the
first one first 15 minutes and then the
next 15 minutes then that's gonna really
do some kind of major problem for our
character so then they're gonna try to
explore the next for the next 15 minutes
and the the effect is actually very
liberating because you wind up not
worrying about how you're gonna fill up
these pages but more about how you're
gonna trim them down because now you've
got all this material but it also helps
you explore a premise really fully you
have a character let's just take a
classic dramatic construction character
wants something and there's obstacles
okay if they under the first act they we
know what they want we know what the
obstacles are going to be well what is a
character gonna do character doesn't
know what the movies about character
just thinks oh this is this is easy I
can solve this so they try something and
that's in your conceptualization of the
story the character tries the easiest
thing that they can try and then the
filmmaker the screenwriter comes up with
an obstacle why that doesn't
that's a baby 10-15 minutes all right so
now they got to try something else
what's that gonna be and you can develop
it and each sequence has its own
integrity ideally the the paradigm is
that each sequence is going to have
three acts also it's going to have some
kind of setup you don't have to do as
much setup because we know the
characters but you're gonna have to
introduce new circumstances they're
gonna try to get something and then it's
gonna end with some kind of resolution
usually negative because it's positive
maybe the movies over but it leads to
the next sequence and to the next one
and so you wind up with actually a kind
of a nested structure because the scenes
dramatic scenes have the same three acts
that's why I tend to like three acts you
can depends on how you define it but if
you understand it as working with
tension which tension is just putting
something in the audience's mind hope
and fear the character wants something
are they going to get it or not that's
what I'm wondering about and if I care
about the character then I'm going to
stay tuned because I want to see the
answer to that so it's you don't need
more than three acts for that you just
need to set that up and then you need to
develop it and then you get the answer
so each act the act set up the whole
thing
then each sequence has its own ok
character wants something and there's
problems and then each scene has a
character that wants something in
there's obstacles so it's like this
iterative structure that keeps the
audience involved because we're
constantly wondering about what how it's
going to come out for the character and
one thing that we also we cover in the
in the book down science of
screenwriting is this this process of
connection to a main character and what
the theories are about why we have that
and it's certainly important if you come
into a if you're at a park and you come
in up on a tennis game and two people
are really battling each other it may be
interesting but it's not going to be
dramatic to you as you don't know them
but if if you do know one if
one of them and you know that they just
mortgage their house and put everything
on this gain and then you know the other
person is a hustler then every child my
god you've got something
transformational but you have to make
that connection emotionally and so so to
get back about the sequence structure
you have many versions of the three acts
and sequences and then in the scenes and
that is the suspense the tension that
keeps us interesting and we also we have
a chapter on the contrasts in film and
that plays also into this approach which
is that in order to maintain audience
attention the stimulus has to be changed
frequently otherwise you you zone out
you you'll lose connection you'll think
about other things and you need to reset
the audience's brain periodically and
filmmakers do it you can see evidence of
it and changing light and dark loud and
soft fast and slow but you also see it
in tension and release tension
maintained for too long it's tedious but
if you release it and give us a chance
to reset then you can go on and build it
up again and again and again until you
reach the the culmination of the picture
and then finally you try to release it
entirely and then people get people to
say yeah I want to see that movie again
I'm gonna tell my friends I want to see
it is it based on a time limit actually
is there an actual science to the to the
down to the minute of what we can handle
in terms of when we're our mind wanders
I my understanding us and this is
something that Connie might be able to
confirm but our attention can maybe last
about three to five minutes and then we
need to re reset it somehow and dramatic
scenes tend to be about three to five
three minutes usually about three pages
and before you need to have some new
character enters you cut away to
something you have a new development
something to scramble it up so yeah you
I I don't think in fact
the basic premise of this book the
inspiration for making your doing the
science of screenwriting was if you see
patterns in in movies and you see
patterns and the advice about movies is
there a deeper reason for it it's there
a physiological basis for it there's a
there's a cartoon and a New Yorker
cartoon that has it kind of illustrates
the idea there is a an audit or a
theatre a movie theatre and it's filled
with cats okay all the cats are the
whole audience and on screen is a shoe
with a shoelace that's loose okay so
okay a cat's gonna find that completely
enthralling a human being maybe not so
much but what we do find enthralling
you're gonna see the patterns there we
are gonna look at that we're gonna look
for certain things and be satisfied by
certain things so the physiology kind of
determines what we're what we're seeing
on screen so I I kind of see the book as
it as I mentioned it's kind of a
argument subtler okay what's fashionable
what advice is essential what isn't what
do we need to know what do we not need
to know well it's like well go back to
the scientific basis for things and see
is there something there that dictates
it or is it just an option so that
that's part of the inspiration for it
you